to China now where home buyers furious
at the delayed completion of their
properties that they're already paying
for have taken things into their own
hands tens of thousands of them have
begun withholding payments for
unfinished projects across at least 50
cities in the country in response
response China's banking regulator is
urging Banks to extend credit to real
estate developers and support
construction the boycott has also found
fears of financial contagion in China's
real estate sector which accounts for up
to 30 percent of the country's GDP and
is a key driver of growth
but to discuss this further Let's cross
to our correspondent in Taipei so Tsung
Han so good to have you on the program
withholding mortgage payments is it's a
pretty big step what's actually driven
them to this point
the root cause of the unfinished
construction projects is a high degree
of Leverage
um that is the private diversion of
funds originally intended for the
construction of buildings by housing
developers with the impact of covid-19
pandemic on the Chinese economy Banks do
not give loans to the developers funds
do not flow to real estate anymore so
these developers have a big problem with
their cash flow they don't have money to
finish building these properties but
many buyers have put their lifetime
savings into these projects and have
been suffering from the double pressure
of mortgage and rent for a long time now
they just want to stop their loss even
at expenses of the bank's credit rather
than to be totally wiped out
Beijing has taken quite a hard line with
its real estate development developers
but at the same time you know it's not
exactly open to popular activism like
this so I'm interested to know what side
the Chinese government's taking
well uh the government just said that
the key is to ensure that the delivery
of buildings stressing that it would
guide financial institutions to control
risks and work with the People's Bank of
China housing and construction
departments and local governments to
prevent the collapse of these projects
however China's financial institutions
are also in the middle of the housing
crisis itself and have been questioned
for years for their inadequate
supervision lending and even suspected
of corruption in politics and the
business as well as being affected by
the high amount of bad debts playing the
complex role of both
co-conspirators and victims so it's
really hard to say which side that they
are taking
yeah and the
pressure on the Chinese real estate
market is is you know is very well
documented so where is this going to go
from here
the crisis in the real asset sector is
spreading to the banking sector as I
mentioned the total amount of
non-performing loans due to refusal to
repaid mortgage could reach 81 billion
euros as the Communist Party approaches
its 20s National Congress in Autumn and
as Chinese president Xi Jinping secure
his third term in office the worsening
debt problem in China's real estate
market could impact the country's
economic and political stability and in
the process the International Community
and the financial markets will also feel
the pain
okay it's so sung Han in Taipei for us
thanks for the update